you look magnificent what's that what's
the secret tell us what it is a long
life of hard drinking yes you really
think that actually yes some people it's
been a very relaxed life sort of only
tense when one went to work yeah but we
all used to try New York and Broadway in
there in the 50s Jason when Robarts was
one of my great friends one of the great
actors stages stage actors for Canada
and we talked to each other between the
lines is to figure out where we were
going to have a drink after the show
wait you're you've totally straight
you're on a Broadway show you're on the
stage you're great actors and you're out
there saying your lines and in between
when you don't have a line you're you're
talking about where you're gonna go get
a drink
suddenly you say something and then I
say wherever Abby's in PJ Clarke's okay
and you continue on really the audience
never hears because of course we're so
bad when we actually say the right lives
that they couldn't care less anyway but
Jason was a great improviser you know
there's that I did hear there's a
legendary story and I don't know if it's
true but there's a story about you and
Jason Robards in this great era late 50s
and you're out drinking and things got
out of hand and do you know the story
I'm talking about it involves a police
horse is that a laugh of no that's not
true no or yes that is true
absolutely I know I can't quite remember
how it started but of course you can't
you were drunk yeah so how can I tell
how do you expect me to tell the story
there but the officer on on the beach
you know they have the horse horse cops
on Broadway and he came in and he said
you know there's a hell of a lot of
noise down here guys come on try to okay
and then we said come on in and have a
drink with us
and Jason said sure come on in and bring
your horse so we got the horse actually
weird you get the horse into the bar
well it was a very narrow room but it
kind of guided it in and the cop was a
great guy he was unbelievable he sounds
like a great guy but a terrible cop and
Jason bought everybody triple tequila's
and gave the horse one my no true true
and we fed the horse the lapped it up
and suddenly the cops are oh geez I go
get a bit get back on my beat again and
so this guy's really on the job I gotta
get out of my drunk horse and get out of
here and the room was so narrow that we
had to leave the horse out the back and
then turn him around outside in the ante
room and yeah bring him back through the
bar
well it all worked out but it all worked
out a captain no no the captain was
promoted oh the captain was promoted
yeah later on at the horse of course of
course became a staunch member of
Alcoholics
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you